so
last time we discussed glycolysis
as a pathway and just want to remind
everybody that
like all pathways glycolysis has to be
favorable that is
delta g across the entire pathway has to
be less than
zero we spent a lot of time discussing
the regulation of glycolysis
and i just want to revisit this quickly
and remember we discussed that the steps
that are regulated
are those with the biggest quote-unquote
bioenergetic cost
that is the biggest drop in delta g is
um
as uh molecules would proceed across the
pathway
those are shown here the hexokinase step
the phosphofructokinase step
and the pyruvate kinase step of of the
pathway
now this is largely true of most
pathways that we can
that we will consider in that these
regulated steps are often those with the
biggest bioenergetic cost and the
reason for that is is that you know it
makes a lot of sense once you go through
those steps it's very difficult
to go back also you'll note that
these are the steps that regulate
entrance and
exit from the pathway and this
also is something we'll commonly see in
other pathways and also makes
some sense you know just to remind
everybody i
drew up here a skeletonized version of
glycolysis and the most important
regulatory features of it you can just
to remind people that
initially hexokinase is regulated by
glucose 6-phosphate
glucose-6-phosphate negatively regulates
hexokinase and that's because
if the glucose-6-phosphate levels in the
cell go up such that it can't be shunted
to glycogen something we'll talk about
today
or be sent through glycolysis it makes
sense not to trap more glucose
once glucose glucose 6-phosphate enters
the rest of the glycolytic pathway the
key step of regulation is
phosphofructokinase
it of course will have positive
feedback saying let's put carbon into
the pathway
if energy charge is low amp is high
activates it
this molecule fructose 2-6 bisphosphate
that we talked about
earlier today we'll mention again today
can be involved in some other
signaling inputs to allosterically
regulate the enzyme
fbp can feed forward to activate
pyruvate kinase you want to match input
with output
and of course if pep builds up you want
to slow it down
if a downstream product citrate builds
up you want to slow it down
and of course a major output of
glycolysis is atp
and if atp is high no reason to
continue oxidizing glucose carbons
now this regulation
we discussed is often done at the
allosteric level by controlling enzyme
rates that can be by a small molecule
binding as i've shown up here
and it could also be via signaling and
that's really
a place where fructose 26 bisphosphate
as a combination of signaling and
allosteric small molecules comes into
play that is you can have
signaling that controls the enzymes that
generate fructose 2 6
bisphosphate thereby creating an
additional molecule
that can act as an allosteric regulator
of the enzyme pfk
to generate fbp and commit
carbon to glycolysis now
we closed the discussion last time
beginning to discuss
how it is that organisms can make
glucose
obviously this glucose carbon that is
being oxidized to get atp
has to come from somewhere we mentioned
that
plants make glucose during the day when
they have plenty of
excess energy from light from the sun
but then use that glucose
to do constant catabolism to maintain
their atp levels
at night and we as animals
obviously take advantage of this by
eating the glucose that ultimately was
created by plants
um uh you using the energy of the sun
we began to discuss an example of
where us as organisms also
make glucose of course this is not net
production of glucose but
you know for instance if our muscle
cells are working hard
lactate can build up that lactate is
excreted into the blood
that lactate can then be used by the
liver to regenerate glucose and one of
the major jobs of the liver
is to maintain a constant level of blood
glucose
to continue to supply um you know fuel
for various
organs including the muscle to uh be
able to
carry out the work that it needs to do
and so
a major this whole process is called the
corey cycle
and a major job of the liver is thus
generating glucose to maintain blood
glucose levels and the pathways
used to do this is a pathway that we
began to talk about last time
called
gluconeogenesis
and it's really a discussion of
gluconeogenesis that is how can one
build a pathway in plants in the liver
wherever as a way to generate
glucose from something like lactate
now of course we know from lac last time
lactate dehydrogenase can obviously it's
a redox reaction to interconvert with
pyruvate
and what gluconeogenesis really is is
it's a pathway
that cells use to convert pyruvate
or really anything else that can come
into glycolysis
an example being lactate
this of course can happen by the lactate
dehydrogenase reaction
and then once it has that pyruvate turn
that pyruvate
into glucose that's really what we're
talking about
when we're discussing gluconeogenesis
now how can we turn pyruvate into
glucose
well we just discussed the whole pathway
where we could turn glucose into
pyruvate glycolysis
and so this is really the reverse of
glycolysis i said many times that
all enzymes are reversible so why can't
we just run the pathway in the opposite
direction
well hopefully if you've been paying
attention for the last several lectures
you realize there's two problems with
doing that
the first is is that remember
why we're doing catabolism in the first
place is to maintain a high atp adp
ratio
under conditions so that the cell can
use that atp adp ratio to carry out
otherwise
unfavorable processes and so thus at a
very high level
cells can't stop catabolism glycolysis
or whatever
has to continue to maintain atp in the
right range
and so now if we're going to do
something anabolic that is build
something
turn pyruvate into glucose this has to
happen
in the background where catabolism is
still happen
and so at least you need some kind of
way
to control both and prevent this from
being some kind of
futile cycle second
even if that atp level is super high in
the cell
it has extra energy there is still a
thermodynamic problem
with just reversing glycolysis and that
is remember delta g
has to be less than zero for any pathway
to work
and so it then stands to reason that if
glucose
oxidation to pyruvate
if this reaction is favored as it is in
glycolysis
that delta g is less than zero
well under the conditions where that's
occurring if we want to then say well
what about the reverse let's switch
the signs pyruvate to glucose
we know that delta g is the same as it
was in the opposite direction
but now changing the signs from positive
to negative or negative to positive
and so thus delta g for the reverse
reaction
must be greater than zero and therefore
must be spontaneous
is is is not spontaneous and therefore
says that we need to have a different
pathway
simply for energetic reasons if we're
going to go in the opposite direction
now oxidizing glucose releases energy
that's how we keep the atp adp ratio
high
it stands to reason then that we are
going to have to put energy in
if we're going to run in the opposite
direction and so
if we're going to build a pathway from
pyruvate to glucose
and guess we're going to have to add
couple that pathway to atp
adp hydrolysis that is couple it to
something favorable
to now allow this otherwise unfavorable
reaction to happen now
this energy of course in plants can come
from the sun we'll discuss that in great
detail when we get to photosynthesis
however for the sake of you and i
i guess what it says is if you think
about this
if you release energy from glycolysis it
makes sense then you have to add energy
if you're going to do gluconeogenesis
but remember to satisfy all the laws of
thermodynamics the net
energy lost to the universe is going to
be um
it's you know must exist which means
that it is going to
cost more energy to make glucose then
you're going to get back
from breaking it down that's just
hopefully fits with your intuition and
it actually i guess is good
news because when are we going to do
anabolism when are we going to store all
these excess calories as glucose
well we're going to do it if we overeat
and if we overeat and it costs us energy
in the form of calories to actually
store that energy for later
i guess it means that when we overeat we
don't have things quite as bad as it
could have been all right now let's get
back to
the how one can actually do this
so if we want to think what is a pathway
that we can build to get from
pyruvate back to glucose well we know
we're going to have to
burn some atp to do it but what are the
issues with simply
reversing glycolysis well we can come
back here and say well
what was driving glycolysis in the first
place and it was these big steps
of free energy change at hexokinase
phosphofructokinase and pyruvate kinase
whereas many of these other reactions at
least under these standard conditions
that are estimated to exist in cells are
relatively close to equilibrium so
there's really no problem
with reversing glycolysis across here or
across there
the real issue comes from getting around
the hexokinase the phosphofructokinase
and the pyruvate kinase step these are
the places where the most
energy is released if you will when
you're going through glycolysis
so those are the steps we're going to
have to add energy
in order to reverse build a pathway that
goes in the opposite direction
and allows you to start with pyruvate
and end up with glucose
and so what we will find is that
gluconeogenesis
and glycolysis
use
many of the same
enzymes however not all of the enzymes
are the same because we need different
enzymes
if we're going to get around this
hexokinase
phosphofructokinase and pyruvate kinase
steps of the pathway and so for
gluconeogenesis
we essentially need four new enzymes
in order to get past those places so we
need a new enzyme called
glucose 6 phosphatase
and glucose 6 phosphatase is going to
allow us to get from
glucose 6-phosphate
and turn it back into glucose all right
we're going to need an enzyme
fructose 1 6 bis phosphatase
which is going to allow us to take fbp
and turn it back into fructose
6 phosphate and then we're going to need
two enzymes to get around
the pyruvate kinase step these are two
enzymes called
pep ck and pc
that stands for phosphoenol pyruvate
carboxykinase and pyruvate carboxylase
i'll
discuss these in great detail in a
minute and these are going to allow us
to get
from pyruvate
back to pep
also essentially i'll add them up here
to this diagram
so to get back from pyruvate to pep two
enzymes
pyruvate carboxylase and
phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase to get from fructose
1 6 bisphosphate to fructose 6-phosphate
an enzyme called fbp ace
and to get from glucose 6-phosphate back
to glucose
an enzyme called glucose six
phosphates
okay now of course if you think back
we're also going to need to balance
electrons in the pathway
remember glucose to pyruvate is an
oxidation reaction that is we're
generating nadh
that means to go in the reverse
direction we need a source of entered
nadh
to reverse that gap dh reaction i just
want to point out that
you're only doing gluconeogenesis if
cells have plenty of energy
what does plenty of energy mean well
that means the atp
adp ratio is high because you're doing
lots of catabolism
but if you're doing lots of catabolism
and the atp adp ratio is high that also
means the nadh nad plus ratio
is high and so you can think of the
nad regeneration by gluconeogenesis
as being for all intents and purposes an
alternative to fermentation if you will
as a way to keep catabolism going that
is you're only doing this
if you have plenty of nadh around and so
dealing with that electron balance is
less of an issue okay now let's discuss
briefly how some of these enzymes work
so glucose 6-phosphate
and fructose-1-6-bisphosphatase are very
straightforward effectively all they are
is simply removing
a phosphate that's very favorable
remember when we did those reactions the
hexokinase and phosphofructokinase
reactions in glycolysis that we had to
couple otherwise unfavorable things
adding a phosphate group
to atp hydrolysis this is the reverse of
that and so the reverse of that delta g
is going to be less than zero delta g
less than zero means
we just have a phosphatase there just
like you might have on a kinase enzyme
that's very straightforward but there's
a much bigger issue
to get around this other step this
pyruvate kinase step
remember equilibrium strongly favored
pep to pyruvate conversion that was one
of the reasons why we could use that
step to
maintain a high atp adp ratio in cells
well now the issue becomes how can we
trap that phosphate
back onto pyruvate while generating
phosphoenol pyruvate how one does
that is an issue
even if the atp adp ratio is high it's
never high enough
to reverse pyruvate kinase on its own
and so we need a new pathway
with two steps in it that's why there's
two enzyme
pc and pepsi k that are there to create
a pathway
where pyruvate
to pep now becomes favorable that is
where delta g not prime is less than
zero that is
the equilibrium favors it to the right
and under cellular conditions
this pathway can actually happen such
the cells can net make
um glucose now these are two steps
both of which require atp and so you
effectively get one atp
from pep to pyruvate conversion it costs
you two atps
or two atp equivalents to go back from
pyruvate
to pep which makes sense you should have
to spend more energy to go upstream
than you get back coming downstream all
right
here's how this pathway works
so
this is pyruvate the first reaction
catalyzed by
pc which stands for pyruvate
carboxylase
couples atp
hydrolysis
to addition
of a co2
that generates this intermediate
which is called oxaloacetate
often abbreviated oaa for oxaloacetic
acid
that oxaloacetate is then
decarboxylated that is the co2
that is lost is
remove that was added is removed this
reaction
is coupled to gtp
and is catalyzed by this enzyme
fck or pep
carboxy
kinase and
and uses that phosphate from gtp to trap
pyruvate in the enol form as pep
or phosphoenol pyruvate
great so the
once you've regenerated pep
now that pep gets to this
flat part if we go over here to our
delta g
place so now it can easily run back
across this
flat part of the curve that is go
through
enolase
phosphoglycerate mutase
phosphoglycerate kinase
gap dh taking advantage of the high
nadh nad plus ratio that would exist
when you're doing gluconeogenesis
trios phosphate isomerase aldolase
this generates a d-hat and a
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate they can then
combine to give a
fructose 1-6 bisphosphate
now we get back here to now we have this
steep part there
but rather than going through fbp
we can just have a phosphatase
fructose 1 6 bisphosphatase that
releases the phosphate
now we have fructose
6-phosphate that fructose 6-phosphate
can then go through glucose 6-phosphate
isomerase
and generate glucose 6-phosphate
that now gets back to this other steep
hill so this is relatively flat now you
have this steep hill around hexokinase
but rather than coupling it to adding
the atp adp hydrolysis you just remove
the phosphate with
glucose 6 phosphatase and in the end
now we have a pathway using
these for
extra enzymes that
give us a way to start a pyruvate and
run the opposite direction
and generate glucose
and you can do so in a way that is
thermodynamically favorable in other
words
we can start with two pyruvate
and use four
atp
two atp for each pirate so
pyro an atp to turn pyruvate twice into
oxaloacetate so that's two
and then another atp at phosphoglycerate
kinase
to go from um to go
backwards there to get to go from uh
um to to to run that reaction backwards
plus to gtp
those two gtp are effectively the
equivalent
of an atp so this would be six atp
equivalents why are the gtps the
equivalent of atp
i just want to point out that cells have
enzymes
that basically can interconvert
atp and gdp or really any nucleoside
triphosphate and diphosphate
to gdp plus adp
this has a delta g not prime
that is effectively zero and so cells
basically match
their atp to adp ratios with any other
ratios of nucleoside triphosphates and
dry
and diphosphates because of this
reaction and so that's why the two
gdp are roughly an atp equivalent
so we'll just call it 6 atp plus
2 nadh
to reverse the gap dh step
that gives us 680p plus
2 nad plus
plus 6 inorganic phosphate
plus a glucose
the delta g
not prime for this entire coupled
pathway
is on the order of negative 9
kcals per mole the delta g less than
zero
equilibrium lies to the right net
synthesis
of glucose is favorable
and so if we just think about this in
atp terms
remember when we discuss glycolysis you
harvest
net two atp from
conversion of glucose into two pyruvate
if we reverse the reaction
doing gluconeogenesis in atp terms we
have to invest six atp
to turn that pyruvate back into glucose
makes sense we didn't make a perpetual
motion machine both pathways are
favorable
but it costs more energy to make a
glucose then we can get out
by burning the glucose should say the
energy isn't just the atp
there's also this nadh that nadh
that's produced from glycolysis also is
storing energy if you will from
oxidation
and an nadh nad plus ratio and you're
consuming that
going in the opposite direction
you only do glucaneogenesis if you have
a high atp adp ratio of course
and a high nadh nad plus ratio
that is if you have it under the right
conditions to actually
run this pathway and have it make sense
for the cell all right
now i want to discuss briefly how these
enzymes and gluconeogenesis work i'm not
going to spend time on
fructose 1 6 bisphosphatase or glucose
6-phosphatase
as i said before this is just a
hydrolysis of that phosphate alcohol
bond that's
relatively straightforward but i do want
to spend time
on pyruvate carboxylase and pep
carboxy kinase because you know this
introduces a new reaction
carboxylation but it also introduces
a new concept in metabolism
that is actually quite important in
eukaryotic cells
and that is this issue of
so-called compartmentalized
metabolism and of course you've learned
in
introductory biology that a big
difference between eukaryotes and
prokaryotes is eukaryotes have
all of these organelles that is these
membrane-bound structures within cells
that carry out various functions
so one reason that it's useful to have
these different
membrane-bound organelles is it creates
different compartments within the cell
what does that mean well if you have
different
compartments
that means you can create different
conditions
within each compartment and that's very
important for metabolism well why is
that important for metabolism well
because remember
whether or not reactions are favorable
depend on delta g
right which of course is dependent on
the equilibrium constant
which is related to delta g not prime as
but also
to the ratio of the products and
reactants
within that compartment and so by having
different compartments you can have
different ratios of metabolites say
a different ratio of atp to adp
or a different ratio of nadh
to nad plus having those different
ratios
means that because delta g
is proportional to the ratio
of the reactants over the products
i'm sorry products over reactants
by having different ratios of things
like atp and adp
nadnadh you can make different reactions
more or less favorable
depending on which compartment in the
cell
that they're located now it turns out
that glycolysis
and most of gluconeogenesis takes place
in the cytosol of eukaryotic cells
the cytosol is basically the space
inside the cell that's not inside
another organelle however pyruvate
carboxylase
is a reaction that takes place in
mitochondria
because mitochondria have a particularly
high
atp adp ratio and it turns out this
helps favor
the pyruvate carboxylase reaction and so
we'll talk a lot about reactions in the
cytosol versus the mitochondria
but basically here's glucose to pep
whether you do that in one direction by
glycolysis or the other direction by
gluconeogenesis
that happens in the cytosol as does
turning that pep
into pyruvate but if you're going to
reverse the reaction
eukaryotes take advantage
of a different compartment the
mitochondria
with a high atp
to adp ratio and basically
in the mitochondria
turn that pyruvate into oxaloacetic acid
that is carry out
the pyruvate carboxylase reaction and
then
that pyruvate carboxylation reaction
generates oxaloacetic acid and then
pepsi k
can either in the mitochondria or in the
cytosol
generate pep and so
here's a place where one can run one
reaction pep to pyruvate to make atp in
the cytosol
but a different reaction pyruvate
carboxylase to turn pyruvate into
oxaloacetic acid
that would then be used for pepsi k to
turn that
back into pep and have that take place
in in the mitochondria i want to point
out just so you know for
mcat exams and things like that
pepsi k is classically defined as a
cytosolic
activity at least in terms of
gluconeogenesis although there is a
mitochondrial isoform of pepsi k and
it's at least somewhat debated
there's some evidence that at least in
some tissues that might be important for
for um for gluconeogenesis as well and
so that's why i draw it as
pepsi k using oxaloacetate to pep
either in the mitochondria or in the
cytosol because that's
an area of active investigation right
now
all right let's start by talking about
how does pyruvate carboxylase work
this is an example of a carboxylation
reaction that is adding a co2 group to a
molecule
to make a carbon-carbon bond that purple
co2
is added to the ch3 of pyruvate to make
oxaloacetate and
how this happens in many cases uses a
cofactor
and that cofactor is called biotin
biotin like many cofactors is a
vitamin and this provides a useful
functional group in this case it uses
enzymes that use biotin use atp
to basically drive co2 addition to
biotin
and then that co2 on the biotin is then
activated to be transferred to another
molecule
in a carboxylation reaction all right so
what does
biotin look like i will draw it for you
so this here would be biotin i've drawn
it
in the enolate
form of biotin i'll draw it in a
different way in a second
biotin is typically
bound to a
lysine molecule in the active site of an
enzyme
that uses this and so this here is
basically a peptide bond
between the amino group
the terminal amino group the epsilon
amino group
of the side chain of a lysine in
a residue that basically makes a peptide
bond to
link biotin into the active
site of the enzyme that's using it
biotin is often drawn in the keto
form and the active part of biotin
is basically this top part of the
molecule and so
to draw it to see differences between
the enolate and keto form
i just want to show that quickly i drew
it in
the enolate form because it's easier to
see
i think how it
okay so this here would be
the keto form where how biotin is drawn
most commonly and basically
the reaction the way biotin picks up a
co2 is as follows
and that is co2
can exist
particularly under basic conditions as
co2
or
as
this is bicarbonate
okay so bicarbonate turns out some
enzymes
use co2 directly some enzymes
use bicarbonate it turns out that
pyruvate carboxylase uses bicarbonate
so biotin bound in the active site of
pyruvate carboxylase
will utilize bicarbonate in the
following way
and i'll just point out that the ph of
the mitochondria
is also more basic which also helps this
pyruvate carboxylation
reaction all right so what happens is
this
bicarbonate is phosphorylated
by atp
this phospho
intermediate can then react with this
active site here of
biotin to
release the phosphate and now
you now have this co2 group that's
activated co2 group that's
attached to the biotin
here's pyruvate drawn in the enol
form look back in your notes about how
it
to interconvert it between the keto and
enol form i've shown that
several times and then
this then can end up
adding the co2 to the
end of pyruvate to generate
oxaloacetic acid plus regenerate
the biotin cofactor in
the right form it'll be the keto form
which can then get back to the enol form
and it's ready to do another catalytic
cycle and so basically pyruvate
carboxylase
uses atp to produce this carboxylated
biotin
and then uses that to add the co2
to pyruvate to generate oxaloacetic acid
now i want to point out that oxaloacetic
acid
is both an alpha-keto acid
like pyruvate was and it's a beta-keto
acid
and so this ketone
is alpha to that carboxylic acid
and it's beta to that carboxylic acid
so it's both an alpha and a beta
keto acid and it turns out that the way
pepsi k works is it takes advantage
of the favorable decarboxylation of a
beta-keto acid which we talked about
last time along with gtp
to phosphorylate pyruvate and trap
it in the enol form and so this is how
pepsi k works so i'm going to draw
gtp in this very stylized way
so guanine with three phosphate groups
there's oxaloacetate
that decarboxylates
the takes advantage of this being a beta
keto acid to decarboxylate
and add the phosphate
and that's how we can generate pep
okay great and so that's how you can
build a different pathway
that uses atp and gtp for energy input
in order to run glycolysis in the
opposite direction
gluconeogenesis all right
so how is gluconeogenesis
regulated well just like the principles
we talked about in glycolysis
it works in a way that makes sense and
so you can guess that the steps that are
going to be regulated
are exactly the ones that you um
my guess they were the same steps
that were regulated running glycolysis
it's going to be
these big changes where energy
changes occur across the pathway which
are also the entrance and exit
of the pathway and basically
regulation has to be reciprocal so in
glycolysis
you want to increase glycolysis under
conditions
where you need to produce atp
and you want to decrease glycolysis
if you have enough atp
or enough of another downstream product
such as citrate all right well
gluconeogenesis
is going to be exactly the opposite
you certainly want to don't want to do
gluconeogenesis
if you need energy release if you need
atp you don't want to run
gluconeogenesis
however you want to increase
gluconeogenesis
if the cell has atp excess
you also want to do it if you have
excess
of other products like citrate
because why
go through the trouble of sending things
down glycolysis if you've
no way to put it you might as well
instead make glucose
or shunt that glucose off to produce
glycogen and so
let me just add
that regulation
here and so major regulators
of gluconeogenesis are as followed
and so high levels of citrate is going
to
stimulate fructose 1 6 bisphosphatase
so high levels of citrate will inhibit
things coming through glycolysis
and activate gluconeogenesis by acting
at
fructose 1 6 bisphosphatase
to match the energy considerations
if you have high levels of amp
energy charge is low want to stimulate
glycolysis
at phosphofructokinase similarly
that's going to inhibit gluconeogenesis
at fbp ace and it turns out high levels
of adp i'm sorry
low yeah high levels of adp low energy
charge also inhibits
um pepsi k because you also don't want
to try to generate
um pep under those
conditions
great all right now
in animals we also want to regulate
glucose catabolism and production
under signaling control and this gets
back to this
other topic we talked about such as the
liver's job being to maintain a constant
level of blood
sugars most of you are very familiar
with blood sugar control through
diabetes
you've probably heard that this is under
hormonal control that the job of insulin
is to lower blood glucose
and you also have hormones like
epinephrine or glucagon
whose job is to raise blood glucose why
do you want to raise blood glucose well
if you have some kind of fight-or-flight
response you see that lying
and you need to run away your body has
this adrenaline rush that's what
epinephrine
is that basically wants to supply more
energy to your muscles so that you can
run away effectively so it turns out
both
insulin and glucose act on lots of
tissues in the body i'm going to focus
on what they do in the liver and that's
because in the liver
this is a major organ that regulates
blood glucose
levels so if you have excess glucose
around
what do you want to do you want to
stimulate glucose uptake into cells its
metabolism and its storage
and so insulin with high blood sugar
basically wants to stimulate
taking glucose into the liver and
storing it
as glycogen if you want to run away from
the lion well now you have epinephrine
around you want to make sure that as
you're consuming that glucose in your
blood that you're continually making
more
and so you want the epinephrine to
stimulate release of glucose
either from gluconeogenesis or from the
breakdown
of glycogen and both of these hormones
act insulin and epinephrine
act at a level where they can regulate
enzymes of glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis as well as
entry and exit of glucose monomers in
and out of
glycogen and so this is
an example of how
fructose-2-6 bisphosphate works and so
remember you learn from
professor yaffi that epinephrine
acts via cyclic amp
signaling which turns on a kinase
protein kinase a and that protein kinase
a
can regulate enzymes that produce or
break down
basically these enzymes that produce or
break down fructose 2-6 bisphosphatase
which in turn regulates pfk activities
such that you can match your need to
burn that glucose
versus doing gluconeogenesis in the case
of the liver so you can do enough
gluconeogenesis
in order to have glucose around
for um the body to use
in that flight or flight response being
driven by epinephrine
now a major effect
of insulin and epinephrine signal
signaling though
is actually on release or
storage of glucose molecules in glycogen
and i alluded last time in talking about
the regulation of hexokinase
the glucose 6-phosphate is basically the
entry point
to get glucose units in and out of
glycogen and i want to discuss how
you add and subtract those glucose
units into storage polymers now i'm
going to discuss it in the context of
glycogen storage in humans
but remember plants actually store
things
also as glucose polymers the chemistry
is very similar but
obviously the regulation is very
different
now you'll hopefully recall
that from past lectures that the
storage polymers of glucose glycogen
in human starch in plants are basically
these alpha 1 4 linkages of glucose
molecules remember there was a
non-reducing end and
reducing end to the molecule so starch
was a straight chain polymer
glycogen had these alpha 1
6 branch points that made this branch
polymer where there's
lots of non-reducing ends and a single
reducing end and each of these
non-reducing ends is a polymer
of glucose molecules with this alpha one
four linkage
that at the branch point has this alpha
1 6 linkage to
make this long chain branched polymer
now when we discussed this at the time i
mentioned that this is useful because
you have all these non-reducing
ends that can be used to add or subtract
glucose monomers
and that's great this is a nice compact
form of storage with lots of places to
put or remove glucose from
to either store it quickly insulin
driving glucose storage or remove it
quickly
epinephrine driving release of glucose
from
from the glycogen and so if we're going
to have a way to
add glucose polymers or break them down
those are two separate pathways just
like glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
reciprocal activities but we needed two
pathways to do it
because it has to be delta g has to be
less than zero for each pathway to work
also we have to be able to regulate
these separately because we don't want
to have
a feudal cycle now
the way you add and subtract
glucose polymers to glycogen
acts through glucose
6-phosphate being first converted
to glucose 1-phosphate
so this here is alpha
glucose 6-phosphate remember it's alpha
because i drew that hydroxyl at the one
position pointing down
this obviously can enter glycolysis
can come in from glucose
by a hexokinase all right
this is first converted via a mutase
reaction to move the phosphate from the
six
to the one position of glucose
so this here is glucose
one phosphate the way the mutate
reaction works is exactly the same
analogous mechanism that i draw
explain for phosphoglycerate mutation
glycolysis
moves the phosphate in this case from
the six to the one position
of glucose and then once you have that
glucose one phosphate
that can be added to
a non-reducing end of a glycogen
polymer using an enzyme called
glycogen synthase
gs so that'll give me a glycogen
molecule with one additional monomer
added to the non-reducing end of the
polymer
and you release that glucose back off
by a different pathway a different
enzyme
called phosphorylase
all right now
the activity of
these enzymes glycogen synthase and
phosphorylase that is the
pathway to add glucose one phosphate
glucose monomer to the polymer
versus remove it from the polymer
is under signaling control under
hormonal signaling
control in animals and basically
that hormonal signaling works as
follows
so
so phosphorylase
can be phosphorylated
or dephosphorylated
via a signaling enzyme an enzyme like
phosphorylase
kinase which is downstream of
pka which is downstream of
epinephrine signaling okay
and so when phosphorylase is
phosphorylated
by phosphorylase kinase that is has a
phosphate group
added is a signaling cascade it is in
the active state
and when it's dephosphorylated it's in
the
inactive state
well glycogen synthase also
is subject to regulation by phos protein
phosphorylation
on the enzyme by a kinase except this
has the opposite
relationship so when it is
in the phosphorylated state it is
inactive
but it is in the non-phosphorylated
state
it is active and so
protein kinase a which is downstream of
epinephrine can both
activate phosphorylation of
phosphorylase
and glycogen synthase and that makes
sense
you want to release glycogen glucose
monomers from glycogen
you turn on by phosphorylation the
pathway to release them
and you turn off the pathway to store
them
another kinase that phosphorylates
glycogen synthase is a
kinase called gsk or glycogen synthase
kinase
this kinase is inhibited by
insulin signaling and so this is
a negative of a negative
right so effectively a negative of a
negative
will keep it in the inactive
state and so insulin
by inhibiting the ability of gsk to put
glycogen synthase in the inactive state
will make glycogen synthase active
and when you have high insulin around
that activates glycogen synthesis
and you store glucose monomers as
glycogen
get them out of the blood okay
now let's discuss
how we can
the chemistry that allows us to do this
glycogen synthase
and phosphorylase reactions
now as we go through this what you will
see is is that
when we break down the polymer energy is
released so that's going to be breaking
down a polymer that's
the right direction of entropy and so
that's going to be released
and storing it is going to require
energy that is going to have to have
some energy input
to build a polymer but nature actually
does this in a way
that is actually quite efficient
first let's talk about how
you store
glucose 1-phosphate units by adding them
to glycogen
so this uses energy input from
utp which is an atp equivalent for
exactly the reason i described earlier
that is because
atp plus udp like any other
inner conversion of nucleoside
triphosphates and diphosphate
is very close to equal herbilibrium so
the utp-udp ratio
should be similar to the atp to adp
ratio and so utp is really an atp
equivalent
but nature for whatever reason decided
to use utp here
and it generates a nucleoside sugar
called udp glucose and so
let me show you what that is
so here is glucose one
phosphate
i will draw a stylized version of
utp here
and so this molecule with the udp
added to the glucose is
udp glucose
this will also generate a pyrophosphate
and that pyrophosphate can be hydrolyzed
to generate two inorganic phosphates
effectively like building any other
polymer
by doing this downstream keeping that
product
of the first reaction low helps pull
that reaction forward for
polymer synthesis this udp
glucose can now which
can now react with the
non-reducing end
so this here will be the non-reducing
end
of the polymer that's the
oh group at the four position at the
non-reducing end
and so
that then generates that
alpha one four bond
to add to the polymer so here we have
glycogen
n plus one plus releases
udp and so the net
to add a glucose one phosphate to the
non-reducing end of the growing glycogen
polymer
is net conversion of a utp
to a udp so that is one atp
equivalent to add glucose one phosphate
to the to the um
to the end of the polymer now of course
you had it to also have an atp from
hexokinase
to capture that glucose phosphate to
begin with
but effectively this is two
atp molecules to add
a glucose to
glycogen all right
now if we're generating starch that's
all we have to do just build a long
polymer but if we're making glycogen
remember
glycogen has all of these branch points
on them as well and to do the branch
points you basically have to make
this alpha 1 6 bond which then gives you
two
new non-reducing ends that you can add
more
subunits to the way nature does this
is as follows and so
if i just draw this here in a
stylized way it turns out once you get
to
about seven
units here in the growing polymer so
this is the reducing end
and this is the non-reduced end of the
polymer
and so the polymer is growing by adding
things to that end
once you get about seven there's an
enzyme that will basically
cleave this and move it and make a new
alpha 1 6
bond okay
here we go we have our reducing
our non-reducing end and basically
transfers
these seven units over and now we have
two non-reducing ends that we can
continue to grow the polymer from
you can think of this kind of like the
airplane analogy right when you
load an airplane at least the way that's
most efficient
the people who are sitting in the back
of the plane they get on first
but then they're and there the last
people off the plane because you add
basically to these non-reducing ends and
then you subtract
from those non-reducing ends and so the
first glucose added the one at the
reducing
end is the last one that is going to be
removed all right
now phosphorylase is the enzyme that
allows you to do the opposite that is to
break that alpha one four bond
and release monomers and it's called
phosphorylase because it uses phosphate
to break that alpha 1 4 bond
taking advantage of the fact that
breaking down the polymer is favorable
and actually releasing the glucose from
it again is a glucose one
phosphate and so at the non-reducing end
of the molecule
so this here
so this here would be the non-reducing
end of the glycogen polymer
you basically have a
phosphate molecule that
takes that off so you have a glycogen
and minus one
plus
a
glucose one phosphate
which can now undergo a mutated reaction
back to glucose 6-phosphate that could
then be released from the cell if it's a
liver
or it could be burned in glycolysis now
obviously if you're doing breakdown
that is you're chewing back from
non-reducing ends
eventually you're going to hit a
situation
where
you come to where there's just a nub
here with an alpha 1
6 bond there that is chew it back till
you hit
this single monomer with a non-reducing
end here
to this alpha one six break point turns
out you just
cleave off that nub if you will
and so that nub is then just released as
free glucose
so other than release of that nub what
it means is
is that you actually basically
get no atp to actually break down in the
phosphorylase reaction
so the net cost to store a glucose one
phosphate molecule
is one atp via the
utpdudp conversion in the glycogen
synthase
reaction and you get that one glucose
one phosphate back
and so two atps to put a glucose into
glycogen
and then you get it directly back out as
a
glucose one phosphate that's a
phosphorylated glucose that can then
enter glycolysis so that's one less
phosphate you need to spend
on glycolysis and so it's incredibly
efficient
to store glucose in that way and so it's
actually slightly greater than one atp
to store it as glycogen because you lose
an atp with that
nub removal at the branch polymer but
for all intents and purposes it costs 1
atp
to store your glucose as glycogen
which is pretty amazing all right
now before i leave the topic of sugar
storage
i want to make some comments on some
sugars that are stored in forms
other than glucose i want to talk about
these because these sugars are of course
important parts of our diet
and so as we've
mentioned in last prior lectures two of
these sugars
are sucrose
and lactose so remember sucrose is a
disaccharide of glucose
plus fructose and lactose is a
disaccharide
of glucose plus
galactose so those are storage forms of
sugar
sucrose in the case of plants lactose in
the case of
of milk made by mammals and so
to break those sugars down
basically you break the disaccharide now
you have the glucose molecules you know
how to handle that's glycolysis
but i want to spend a little bit of time
how you deal with the fructose and the
galactose that you get out from these
sugars
because this actually relates to some
things that i'm sure you've all
read about in the news for instance
fructose as a sugar in our diet
is actually quite controversial
lots of stuff out there that says
fructose was cooked up in the devil's
kitchen
and is this evil thing um there's
actually others who argue that oh
fructose is the same as glucose the same
number of calories
there's both sides of the debate both
sides are actually making factual claims
and i want you to understand the
biochemistry
so you can actually judge for yourself
who's right in those claims all right so
let's start with talking about how you
metabolize fructose
and so fructose
is first captured by phosphorylation
to generate fructose
one phosphate okay this is carried out
by an enzyme
called keto hexokinase
ketohexal kinase is a gut that's present
as a enzyme that's present in your gut
and your liver
and so fructose in the diet from
breaking down sucrose or from high
fructose corn syrup whatever
is captured with keto hexokinase to make
fructose one phosphate
turns out that phosphofructokinase our
old friend from glycolysis
is less efficient than keto hexokinase
but can also carry out this reaction
and remember what does it do in
glycolysis it adds a phosphate to the
one position of fructose 6-phosphate
or can also add a phosphate to the one
position of fructose to give you
fructose one phosphate okay
once you have this fructose-1-phosphate
which remember is not
in glycolysis it can be a substrate
for the glycolytic enzyme
aldolase what does aldolase do in
glycolysis
it splits fbp into dihydroxyacetone
phosphate and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
well here you only have a phosphate on
the one position
and so if you look back at how aldolase
works what you'll see
is that if aldolase acts on fructose one
phosphate
you'll generate a dihydroxyacetone
phosphate that phosphate will go to the
dihydroxyl in half
which of course is perfectly good
substrate for glycolysis the other
product
of aldolase acting on
fructose-1-phosphate
is just
glyceraldehyde without the phosphate on
it
and then there's another enzyme that
will phosphorylate
glyceraldehyde to generate
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate which can
then
also of course enter glycolysis
and so fructose is a hexose just like
glucose
you generate two trioses d-hap and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate that costs
you 2 atp to do it
exactly the same cost is what you spent
to get glucose to make d-hap and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
and so people are absolutely right when
they say
metabolizing fructose has exactly the
same caloric
cost as metabolizing glucose
two atps to get it into the trioses and
then whatever you get out of it you get
out of it
two atp four atps so net two atps if you
just do fermentation
more if you do complete oxidation but
the bottom line
is is that from that standpoint you get
exactly
the same number of calories from burning
glucose versus
fructose however i want to point out
that the regulation will not be the same
and that's
because in this fructose metabolism
you will notice that there was no
glucose 6-phosphate
and no fbp
generated that means you are avoiding
all of the feedbacks that control
how much glucose you send to glycolysis
first the glycogen remember that's what
glucose 6-phosphate does
acting on trapping sugar and more
importantly
you're actually not using
phosphofructokinase
in a way to fit with the rest of the
feedback
regulation i also show that here
on this slide it's basically a
better version of what i drew
up here and i now want to point out
this storage of citrate and this
feedback
regulation of citrate so we'll talk
about
the specifics of this more in other
lectures
but it turns out citrate is the
precursor
for how one stores carbon as fat
and so if you're putting fructose
glucose into the system
and citrate is too high it'll shut off
phosphofructokinase and stop
carbon coming down the system shunting
it and said to glycogen or just saying
don't give me any more glucose at all
if i'm doing the same thing with
fructose those feedbacks don't exist
citrate doesn't feed back
on any of the enzymes that are regulated
for
fructose metabolism and so the idea is
carbon keeps getting dumped into citrate
which ultimately ends up as fat and this
is really underlies at least on a
theoretical basis
why there may be a connection between
fructose
and obesity or metabolic syndrome i've
posted
articles on stellar one from the popular
press
one from a scientific journal that
discusses the controversy discusses this
but now at least you have the background
to draw some of your own
conclusions okay that's fructose
metabolism
what about galactose metabolism
well galactose metabolism interfaces
with effectively
glycogen metabolism or at least glucose
one phosphate
or sorry udp glucose and does so
in a way that is a little bit
non-intuitive but it's actually very
important
to understand galactose metabolism at
least
for those of you who are looking to go
to medical school
turns out that galactose metabolism and
issues with metabolizing galactose
are what underlie a set of rare genetic
diseases
leading to a set of conditions called
galactosemias
i guess if you're a pediatrician you may
encounter these if you're not these are
quite rare although med schools love to
ask about these and certainly they're
very popular on things like
board exams so it's something you should
know about
and so i just want to briefly introduce
galactose
metabolism to you so this is
galactose like all sugars
galactoses initially trapped
by phosphorylation it's
phosphorylated on the one position
to trap it just like fructose
and so this is the lactose
one phosphate remember galactose
is an epimer of glucose so it differs
from glucose here by the stereochemistry
of the hydroxyl group
at this four carbon
and so the way galactose once it's
trapped is galactose one phosphate is
metabolized
is it will react with
udp glucose
so here is udp glucose
from glycogen metabolism drawn in a very
stylized way
that will generate a udp
galactose
and a
glucose one
phosphate which of course
can enter glycolysis
can be stored as glycogen
etc this udp galactose
can then be turned into udp glucose
via an epimerase reaction
and so remember the epimerase reaction
needs to change the stereochemistry of
the hydroxyl group
at this four position such that it's
pointing up in galactose
or pointing down in glucose
the way epimerases work is that they
require a cofactor
that cofactor is nad and they work in
the following way
and so if i just draw
here's the four position
of galactose okay the
four carbon of galactose with the
hydroxyl group
pointing up
on epimerase
you can basically remove a hydride from
the bottom face of the molecule
transfer those two electrons to nad to
generate
nadh now you get this
lactone intermediate
at the four carbon and then you can have
two electrons from an nadh
be added to the opposite face of the
molecule
that regenerates an nad plus and now
we've effectively
changed the stereochemistry at the four
carbon to now be
pointing such the hydroxyl points down
and that's glucose
and so the way epimerases work is they
basically
add and remove and add electrons from
different faces
of the pyranose ring and that changes
the stereochemistry of which direction
the hydroxyl group
is pointing
and so effectively this is how
we metabolize all kinds of different
sugars
either putting them in glycogen
or other starch some other storage
carbohydrate that we can get them
later and then use them in glycolysis as
a way to drive
glucose oxidation as a way to release
energy
um and keep atp high in the cell
all right now i want to shift topics and
begin to discuss how we can
oxidize pyruvate from glycolysis to make
co2
as an alternative to how we can release
energy from carbohydrate oxidation
rather than just use fermentation
now you'll see that the enzymes and ways
that we do this
is going to also be how we make citrate
and so this isn't just about releasing
energy it's also about storing energy
because you'll see
citrate is a precursor for storage as
fat
the reactions downstream of pyruvate
oxidation
also make lots of other useful
intermediates that can be used to
synthesize
other things cells need amino acids
nucleic acids
and so this pathways we're going to
discuss
are going to come up over and over again
throughout
the course now to facilitate this
discussion i'm really going to at least
initially focus
on catabolism and so
to remind you if we do glycolysis by
turning glucose into pyruvate
this involves oxidation
so we need to dispose of those electrons
somewhere
that in other words that nadh has to be
regenerated nad
fermentation of pyruvate into something
like lactate
is a way to do that and allows net atp
production
from glycolysis without the need for
any oxygen however if we're going to
completely oxidize that pyruvate to co2
we're going to generate many more
electrons
as wastes that we have to put somewhere
oxygen is a particularly good electron
acceptor
and so we can reduce oxygen to water as
a way to deal with that electron waste
and that allows us to
just like burning wood release lots of
energy
from glucose by transferring those
electrons ultimately to oxygen
and of course that same process oxygen
to water
if we're using the pyruvate to fully
oxidize it also is necessary
to regenerate the nad to run glycolysis
now ultimately the series of reactions
that allow chemically conversion of
pyruvate to co2
is called the tca
cycle for tricarboxylic
acid cycle or
sometimes referred to as the krebs
cycle and also is referred to as the
citric acid
cycle so tca tricarboxylic acid cycle
krebs cycle citric acid cycle all
synonyms for
the same thing what these
cycles are is basically
a way to take
two carbon units
and those two carbon units can come from
the oxidation of pyruvate
or from the oxidation of lots of other
fuels
and those two carbon units are combined
with four carbon units
you'll see oxaloacetate is the four
carbon unit oxaloacetate from
gluconeogenesis
that oxaloacetate could come from the
pyruvate carboxylase reaction
or it could come as you'll see from the
tca cycle itself
this generates a six carbon
molecule which is
citrate citrate is a tricarboxylic acid
hence the citric acid cycle or the
tricarboxylic acid cycle
and then those six carbon units are
re-oxidized releasing two co2 molecules
back to four carbon oxaloacetate and
hence
this is a cycle now this cycle was
initially described by hans krebs who
predicted
the cycle largely based on chemistry one
of the most amazing feats and discovery
of metabolism
turned out he was right
and thus it's also referred to as his
name the
krebs cycle now lots of oxidation
is happening in this cycle you're
oxidizing the molecule releasing co2
that means lots of energy is released
those electrons ultimately
transfer to oxygen and so we can use
this to make lots of atp
and do lots of other work
where these reactions all occur
is in the mitochondria specifically
in the matrix of the mitochondria
remember the mitochondria from cell
biology
is a double membrane organelle the
innermost
part of the mitochondria is referred to
as the matrix
and these have conditions that favor
the pyruvate carboxylase reaction as i
talked about but also
favor other oxidation reactions such as
those that occur in the tca cycle
and so next time what i will start with
is by being more explicit about what
chemistry is happening to allow
these two carbon units to combine with
oxaloacetate for carbon to generate
citrate
and go over the reactions that then
allow you to run a cycle
to regenerate oxaloacetate
that is run the tca cycle
as a way to oxidize carbon
thanks